hello and welcome to this video playing
as our code run master fluffy shucks
doing for Kings Indian set up as he
usually does it's a cool statistic yeah
I've got fifty percent score against em
seven wins seven losses no draw it not a
single roll yeah he's a very fighting
player so when that does make her [ __ ]
some sense d 5 y am taking this this is
a line that I don't like so much for
white I have to say my development is
quite shaky shaky is wrong so wrong word
is yeah with neglected and I don't like
this so much but ok we'll see what
happens 3333 comes back before I we
should I fine ok but III after I want to
play not a 3-wood to take and
interesting ok nitey to hear in this
position he goes Bishop g4 I guess very
interesting cool very cool play here by
mr. cheat Chuck also okay very cool
it's a very dangerous technician cop
okay so Queen d2 i'm ok let's not waste
time on the smooth I thought I have the
caps on d5 like after this I thought I
can take you five but he has 93 of
course yes ok rap ok maybe queen bee
three or
you can just go back up in 97 or
something it's probably looking for more
active solution as it's a style which I
don't know 93 looks strange after oxy
one unless i'm totally not understanding
things maybe he has some some other
things I guess maybe I Bishop f5 or
something okay so he is going for the
ambitious move as it is typical anyway
so we should f5 or whatever I can also
do this right it cannot take s III hangs
hmm Bishop a 5ft for some and maybe he
can take bishop jakes and then queen a6
check adds a cute variation
so II form Bishop takes it's really this
is happening yeah Rob Bishop takes pawn
takes pretty sick stick and I'm toast
cool that's a cool move so hmm okay cap
you cannot go nighty too at the end of
queen bee to check so will this one can
I take b7 Wow yeah i think i can
actually write it 92 doesn't work it's
not like I want the pawn you know I want
to go back to f3 and then King g2 to
finally get my pieces to some sort of
coordination I don't know if it if I if
I'm able to but might
I get to g2 this is not bad I mean so I
take it let's take it and quit you one
it's the thing oh my god okay um let's
that's just a [ __ ] for a moment if I
take it there is Queenie one I cannot do
this so probably go back you really have
to be exceptionally alert than those
games as constant constant technical
things going on and here you can
probably take and play Queen eat you or
something I mean I have some problems
here with my all of a sudden they're not
all of a sudden I had problems anyway
would taking only for was wrong of
course I thought I can take 17 but the
Queen you want was of course a real
hammer oh groups eh maybe well um I'm
not shipping made that you know what is
this thing here queen bee 70 hmm i don't
care i have quincy six
kf2 mmm but it is a pin right I can do
this you might go on the second anyway I
have to play k-tuned what's why do I do
this here rookie 7 is a key idea hide
mine anyway
check I doesn't even work actually the
chick doesn't do all that much I can
check twice still this okay try yeah
I've got got the better time but I don't
really see a way to do anything here
stay way to play whom I don't don't see
anything wrong haha my jaw is fine i
mean i had had a real rotten position he
played to the opening very well i'm
happy to that i didn't get totally
clogged with them so let's see let's see
what was what's going on here yeah i
have to really look at this again 65
this is irritating me maybe I have to
switch plans now I this is really
something that I had on the board in
games and I didn't really like my
position all that much this is this is
him moving yeah that's no mean be five I
wouldn't be five and and that was that
was wrong I guess because I mean here
clap I mean I'm in bad shape I'm in
really bad shape that it just totally
sucks and this is a strong move of
course a it doesn't have to move it if i
go here yes Bishop before that says
absolutely lost so i already am limited
him to stuff you should appear queen 85
and take syria and TM I'm badly badly
struggling this is this all very strong
very strong play an idea three Bishop is
six in all the engines move yeah that
that's maybe ballet em and Queen 80
yeah the computer shows the way he must
have had the clear clear no question
yeah and black is clearly better we kind
of both move here they've been back and
forth something yeah that's that's
excellent that's excellent for black I
mean I'm having this this crappy I'm
yeah okay we don't really need to talk i
don't i don't argue here with it with
you it doesn't hear me talking is the
thing I mean try that said sets his
moves NAB like blackest Carabella will
win here absolutely so um Bishop f5 is
interesting yeah one key is thing is
that this is possible I mean I'm happy
that I saw those tactics here this is
hot this is the problem losing
everything cat chick classic tragic
check check check check check check mate
that's nice it absolutely loses
everything ok so i had to do this and t
I'm just barely hanging on so and this
was a mistake making my life difficult I
was of course planning this but he has
got gas cap cap cap I didn't talk more I
didn't see the mate of course but Queen
f2 is enough that was my issue and now I
had to do some things a king g2 wasn't
all that bad what did take opg to me
actually hmm I was probably a little bit
I was too irritated here i guess and i
can go here i am that that that is said
that that is equal so I somehow somehow
wriggles out of the
so whatever he allowed allowed me to X
exact said hi and now I'm yeah clean 82
what what I was saying and this was
would have been very awkward whatever I
do here in this is his sketch now that
that would have one hand made here I'm
okay reasonably okay yeah whoopsie to
again was it was an issue I could have
done that immediately ha maybe here I'm
over here I do hold yeah okay the game
the the crucial points were earlier in
the game where he could have could have
could have one deserved its own ok guys
thanks for watching